what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to
Pearl daily where I cover this week's
treachery debauchery and craziness
before I start don't forget to subscribe
to the channel and like the video let's
get this video to 3,000 likes also guys
get yourself a women shouldn't vote
t-shirt today as you already know all
this craziness really is caused by women
getting the right to vote let's take
that away get yourself a women
shouldn't vote t-shirt also guys my
producer King is going to be fighting at
the BX GP contenders show this Sunday on
the 8th of October at the Scala Event
Center in King's cross London if you
want to meet me king and some of the
other people that work here at the
studio make sure that you attend and get
your ticket if you want to support him
and get tickets watch the fight DM him
on Instagram it's it's king omalah
that's k i n g o m a t s o l a type that
on Instagram and get your ticket you can
also find information in the description
and today guys I think we have the final
response from the daily wire so as you
guys know I have been going back and
forth with the entire daily wire all
right I believe that marriage is a bad
deal for men in 2023 and I think it is
negligent to encourage young men to get
married without informing them of the
risks and no I do not think informing
them of the risks is saying yeah the
laws are bad just sign up anyway and
really I would encourage the daily wire
I'm I'm hoping now that I've redpilled
them on marriage that you're going to
see just video after video after video
after video demanding that the laws
change for men demanding that men get
custody this is going to be their first
question that they ask all of the
politicians right
guys no maybe not I don't know let's see
okay so I couldn't believe it guys when
I was younger I I'm still a big Ben
Shapiro fan
but I do think he has it wrong and is a
bit naive when it comes to marriage the
reason being I believe that Ben Shapiro
is under the age of 45 and typically men
that are in a higher socioeconomic
status have a different experience with
women in marriage you know um Google
says that Ben Shapiro is worth over $50
million if you're worth over $50 million
I'm sure you have have a lot easier time
getting women to respect you and listen
to you than say the average Joe that
works down the street now a lot of these
influencers are a bit out of touch with
the average middle American man the
average man in America makes about
$55,000 a year this is a completely
different experience in the level of
resources that they have access to I
mean when you're worth millions and
millions of dollars you can afford the
best divorce lawyers and child custody
lawyers you can't really do that when
you're a workingclass American and this
is why I believe we are going to see
marriage stay in the upper class and
high society but you are going to see it
disappear from the average American
family and Middle
America so Ben Shapiro responds to me um
and I will say I'm getting they're
getting a little bit nicer you know um
when I first I first was you guys
remember personally attacked I was
called an old
spinster by Matt Walsh's wife but now
now pearls getting getting some real
criticism so let's pull up the video
well folks there is something called The
Red Pill movement it's sort of a farri
movement that focuses in on saying the
unsa and now many of the redpilled have
taken the position that it's bad for men
to get married a fascinating debate has
broken out about the value of marriage
it's it's really interesting so there
are a bunch of people on the so-called
redpilled right who have now suggested
that marriage is bad for men that men
should should not get married now the
case that they're making is not the
liberal feminist case that basically men
are useless and terrible and a woman
needs a man like a fish needs a bicycle
or anything like that the case that they
are making is that the stakes of
marriage have been changed by things
like no fault divorce custody
Arrangements the child support payments
and all the rest bousel support that
basically the legal regimen has made it
not a bargain for men to get married now
I agree with with the critique of all of
those policies I think no FAL divorce is
a disaster area I think that the child
custody Arrangements that that basically
always go to Mom no matter what that is
that is a serious problem when you shift
the incentive structure there's a reason
why the majority of divorces the vast
majority of divorces are now initiated
by women that that is not because in the
past women were were wildly abused and
today they are wildly liberated what
that really is is when you shift the
incentive structure and it turns out
that all the risk is now taken by men
women are going to be the ones who
actually activate and push that divorce
button however the red pill have taken
it one step further and now they are
telling young men you should not get
married it's too dangerous to get
married don't get married that's foolish
that's foolish so let's let's go through
some of these arguments because they
become very popular on the right so
let's start with pearl Davis so Pearl
Davis is an anti-feminist who has become
pretty popular a lot of people label her
sort of a female Andrew Tate Al without
the checkered past and here is Pearl
Davis talking about
marriage the tradcon daily wire
conservatives were are saying that
Pearl's just a doom and gloomer who lies
about stats just focuses on the
negatives never the positives and all
the men complaining are just cry babies
and so one day he comes home and he
finds out
that his wife had called the police on
him and told them that the first time
they hooked up 10 years
ago he um he had quote unquote raped her
and the truth of the matter is when a
man has children they're not his kids a
man has no way to have children and
those kids be actually his they're
always hers because the courts give the
women custody 90% of the time and rich
men are really the only ones that have
the money to fight it and the time so I
I ask the daily wire Jeremy Boeing Matt
Walsh um is this just crybabies are they
just are they just their crybaby weak
men who don't man up and want to risk
that so you know it's interesting
because instead of demanding that the
laws change and demanding women face
repercussions for doing this stuff you
guys demand that men need to step up and
take part in a system that discriminates
against them you say oh find a girl that
praise she won't do it but and I had
this thought too until I found a Muslim
girl that did the same thing I found a
Christian girl that did the same thing I
found a Catholic girl it's happening all
over whether you want to believe it or
not it is happening I don't care about
your religion I don't care about your
church this happens everywhere okay so
the argument that she's making against
all these marital policies those those
are correct arguments and nobody is
disregarding the pain of men who have
been wrongfully victimized under these
circumstances where the incentive
structure is completely stacked against
them that is true however the benefits
of marriage are still unbelievable it
does matter who you marry to pretend
that there is no difference between the
person that you marri that it's
happening with Christians and Muslims
and it's all the same that's
statistically untrue there are things
that you can do to mitigate against the
risk of divorce and the person that you
marry is the chief
mitigation the the truth is that in the
Jewish Community we always have a backup
plan in the sense that every marital
contract is a prup every marital
contract is a prup right a Jewish kba is
a prenup it guarantees certain levels of
spousal support for example if you if
you give a get then it it it makes prior
arrangements and all the
rest but one of the throwing out the
baby with the bath water is not the
solution so how about both how about we
revise the system of law but also in the
meantime you do need to find a spouse
and get married to her okay so I wanted
to address a couple things one they did
cut out my whole point of that story
that I was telling in the video and the
point of that story is what they're put
pushing drives men to commit suicide you
could speak to any father's rights
Advocate that works with men to get
custody of their children and they will
tell you the same thing many men in this
process cannot stand the idea of living
life where the entire world thinks
they're an abuser they have no money and
they are essentially paying for their
ex-wife to get railed by other dudes I
mean sorry I got to say it like that but
the idea of that really is death to a
lot of men in this country and a lot of
men do end up committing suicide so I
think that men need to decide for
themselves and the biggest thing that I
am against is shaming men for walking
away from marriage if I pushed a pill
that at a 5% suicide rate after taking
that pill you would tell me that I am
the bad guy for pushing that pill yet
daily wire can push marriage onto men
and the CEO of the daily wire did in
fact call men cry babies that complain
about this stuff and did tell them to
man up and get married I think it is
wrong to shame men for making the
decision to walk away from women and a
lot of times the attributes that men
attribute to marriage could easily be
explained that women tend to marry rich
men rich men I I would argue that people
that make more money in general tend to
be happier than people on the brink of
poverty so a lot of times with the way
they talk about these stats kind of goes
back to female narcissism and giving
women credit for everything the marriage
the women are absolutely the credit for
the man making more money in marriage or
maybe women just like rich men um the
happier men are in marriage well I would
say that rich handsome successful men
that women tend to pick tend to be
happier but they are quite unhappy and
you will see that the suicide rate does
increase after divorce a man is much
more likely to commit suicide after a
divorce course now you could say you
could come back and say Pearl's the bad
guy because well the men are also uh
they might commit suicide if they're fat
broken
alone well yeah I don't I don't promote
that either why would the laws change if
the politicians make money off of the
system if lawyers make money off of the
system the media makes money off of the
system everybody makes money off of this
system so why on Earth would the laws
change if the daily wire keeps telling
young men to sign up buckle up boys sign
up and another thing I'd like to point
out is that in all actuality marriage
isn't the real problem Ben is right
where you can get a prup that lowers the
risk of marriage the real risk for men
in 2023 is having children again I have
spoken to divorce lawyer after divorce
lawyer about this and when men have
children in this country these children
are not theirs they have no right to
these children unless they maybe get
lucky with the right judge and have the
money for a lawyer that can fight it but
mind you guys this is the exception not
the rule and you can see this by the
custody statistics where men
overwhelmingly do not get custody of
their children now as a as a woman that
grew up with nine siblings in a two-
parent home I am very grateful for that
I think that is the ideal but until you
start lowering the risk for men
regardless of what I say you're going to
see less men sign up we need to increase
the value that men get out of marriage
and lower the risk imagine imagine
women imagine this women automatically
get divorced if they get over 150
pounds would more men sign up for that
now I kid right this is this is a joke
but but you see that would be a way
women staying in shape for a lifetime
would be a way to add value um another
way to lowerer the risk is to get rid of
some of the incentives that pay women to
leave I don't believe you will ever see
a return to traditionalism until you
start changing some of the laws I also
question and I wonder if traditionalism
can ever come back now I don't say this
because I don't want it to you know
again as someone that grew up in a two-
parent household with lots of siblings I
think that's the ideal but I also wonder
if social media has diluted the public
so much that it's damn near impossible
for it to come back I don't know you let
me know in the comments now now um Idol
says this is a lot better than Matt's
take yeah because Matt attacked the
person Ben starts attacking the idea
thank you for addressing the actual
point I don't think Pearl disagrees with
you guys that men should never marry
it's the same point the problem is there
are no good ways to find a decent
partner especially for the average man
when the average man man are always in
situationships ones that are devout of
value they're not thinking about
marriage because it's not the right girl
the legal risks of marriage exacerbate
that exactly I am very much PR marriage
I think marriage is a beautiful thing I
think the ideal is two virgins getting
married but I'm not blind to the world
and after interviewing hundreds and
hundreds of men and women and I had the
Epiphany that I've had women of all age
groups on my show no we do not pick for
specific types of women um it's quite
difficult to do that at one point we
were doing I was either producing shows
six days a week um with panelists in the
studio or I had a show of my own that
was six days a week Imagine the amount
of people I spoke to I had the Epiphany
that I really could only out of hundreds
and hundreds of people recommend 5 to 10
women that I would recommend to my
brothers that is a problem and I live in
in London one of the most diverse cities
on the planet I used to live in a
primarily Nigerian African part of
London now I live in a primarily Muslim
part of London on top of that we have
had people from all ethnicities and all
parts of the world on the show um I can
think of people from Italy Spain
Zimbabwe Nigeria the list goes on and on
these problems are coming everywhere and
as much as they want to Discount the red
pill and say that in some way it's
hurting men really it's just talking
about the reality of the situation and
the reality right now is that
traditionalism was 50 years ago and I
hope that it's not dead but it may be in
the future if you are truly serious
daily wire about getting marriage to
return that needs to be the number one
issue that you ask all of the
politicians that you cover and the
number one issue that you ask in all of
your interviews what are the politicians
doing to bring bring men back to
marriage what are they offering them in
return and until you start asking those
tough questions I do not believe that
you really care about marriage coming
back so what I say in the meantime men
should just get married I would say if
you choose to do that be extremely
cautious and I think that's the most
honest answer that you can give now um
another thing they say is that just find
a good woman that prays and the issue
that we get with this is whenever the
stats say something that the left and
the right doesn't like they'll continue
to argue with me for a lifetime for
example there's one stat that followed
40-year marriages marriages that have
been married 40 years or longer and they
found that the real divorce rate is
67% so the divorce rate remember the
divorce rate now 40 50% and a lot of
those marriages they include people that
are separated dead bedrooms and just
haven't divorced yet now there is a
content creator called The Joker better
Bachelor he's a very talented content
creator on YouTube and he actually sent
out a tweet that says watch what women
do not what they say Christian and
right-wing women always speak from their
high horse about how they fight for men
in traditional fairness and equality
under the laws let's look at some
divorce stats shall we they sure do
divorce a lot and I bet they fight for
majority custody of their kids as
statistics show and Duke it out for a
child support in alimon just like the
vast majority of women do I find it
funny to see conservative women get big
mad when men speak out on issues and
then saying right-wing men have turned
on them I'm not right-wing and neither
are many of the Fed Up men with
everything but since you can't put us in
a defined box you don't know what to do
now do you if right-wing women really
cared they'd help change the laws push
for even more handled child custody and
not get divorced but as usual they do
the same thing that other women do then
claim they're different or tradition
traditional and conservative nice try
ladies but it's the same blame game as
always so try again this is from Pew
research with a reasonable sample
size divorced or separated adults and
the religious composition of divorced or
separated adults
74% identify as
Christian let me repeat that for you 74%
identify as Christian and the typical
attack that I get back from the
Christians is those just aren't the real
Christian and then it just becomes a
holy off who's the most holy and how can
I virtue signal if you prayed every day
then you would be a real Christian um
you can't get divorced if you're a real
Christian well the women identified as
real Christians in their 20s and
conveniently at 44 decided no more now I
don't say this in a happy way um
although I'm quite a friendly happy
person so I can't I can't help you know
if that's how how it comes across but it
really truly does make me sad I look at
the places in the world that used to be
filled with children and families and
overwhelmingly I see more singles it's
becoming a very different world to what
I grew up with and I'm 26 years old I
would argue that the daily wire has more
political poll than Fox News nowadays
does with conservatives so you guys
taking a stance on no fault divorce and
asking politicians the tough questions
on how they will incentivize men to get
married again and reduce the risks for
men I would even go as far to push for
men automatically getting custody in
divorce if men if the data has proven
that men raise better children why do we
not automatically give them custody
unless there is some sort of drug
addiction or abuse situation men over
the age of roughly 45 50ish have a very
different view on marriage even the men
that are happily married have likely
witnessed a friend or family member go
through a traumatic divorce and would
not necessarily recommend young men to
get married now we have a clip that is
going viral of an elderly person
advising young men not to get married
what advice would you give to your
younger self don't get
married you're free man you're free in
the world so don't get married please
you know forget about population it will
grow
automatically you know don't get married
don't lose your freedom and indiv
individuality you know and your pride
man you're a man you're always wanted
I'll tell you you're always wanted but
once you got it you're jailed and this
is the reality of the situation many men
are demasculate every day in marriage
and really a man that goes home every
day and is disrespected by his wife and
children is a man in prison modern
marriage is a prison for men they lose
their freedom and have to have man caves
in the corner of their houses to get
away from their wives they're constantly
told that their wies happiness dictates
the future of their marriage on top of
that we have F phrases like it's cheaper
to keep her you see products sold that
say his side and her side and her side
is the majority of the bed why is a man
providing protection and provisioning to
a household and yet is stuck in a corner
of the house in his man cave why our
house is decorated the way the women
want and not the men want men deserve
respect and husbands deserve to have
authority over their own home until
women start understanding this you will
see marriage disappear forever and
unfortunately this is rampant even in
Christian and Catholic churches as a
Catholic this makes me very sad but
unfortunately there are women's groups
that absolutely ruin marriages today
they teach things like Mutual submission
and only submitting to your husband when
he's submitting to God and now while on
paper that sounds nice why does the wife
get to determine when he's submitting to
God on top of that they have started to
allow women preachers to preach in the
church and women to impose their will on
men no no no no no no no all of this
nonsense is really driving men from
churches you're going to start looking
around in your local church and you're
going to notice that men under the age
of 35 are gone nki NADA couples are
disappearing because in all honesty many
of the men in churches don't have a
backbone and still appeal to the whim of
what women want what women want comes
second what men want should come first I
am really tired of seeing these simps
and modern women ruin churches
patriarchy is a good thing men are
supposed to be the head of the household
now speaking of bailing women out of
their bad decisions I am now seeing this
phenomenon of giving porn stars rewards
Mia kifa was a huge porn star I don't
know much about it all I know is that
this woman was huge and I've seen her go
on podcast after podcast after podcast
talking about how exploited she was and
how she really regrets her decisions
then this woman comes out with an only
fans how on Earth can you be exploited
and regret your decisions while also
being on only fans it sounds like you
were just bad at negotiating a good deal
now this woman is being taken seriously
as an actual runway model how insulting
is it to the real models that represent
grace and beauty that we have a tatted
up porn star on runways this is a
disgrace if I was a woman that took
modeling seriously and broke my back to
become a model I would be absolutely
offended in protesting that a post wall
porn star is now beating me for a gig
this is ridiculous we need to stop
catering to women and cater to men that
is not what men want or want to see a
tatted up porn star maybe for the night
but when I think of a model I think of
beauty and elegance and not this
nonsense that they're pushing today
Georgio says you are not a model well no
Georgio obviously she's not so I would
ask whoever's in charge of the modeling
industry not an industry I know much
about um I thought that models were
supposed to be beautiful and represent
the most beautiful women in society why
on Earth do you have a tatted up porn
star up there this is pandering and
catering and us women are sick of being
sold a dream we are sick of being
pandered to and at some point us women
need to get together and tell them we
are
tired so I don't spend a lot of time on
Reddit that's a new um I don't really
understand how how it works but I guess
there's an entire um thread of reddits
opinions of just pearly things so I
guess my producers you're giving this to
me today let's pull it up all right
opinions on just pearly things also
known as Pearl Davis are divided she
advocates for am men's rights and
criticizes feminists but some find her
arguments controversial and
problematic okay Pearl suggests that if
a woman gains weight during pregnancy
it's fair for the man to leave her some
see this as unfair to women who undergo
pregnant related weight gain really
ladies
really it was it was the pregnancy it
wasn't the Doritos you were
eating I mean I I I think this is a good
thing honestly weight is in your control
these women act like you don't think in
way a woman's choosing to get divorced
if she knows I if she knows her husband
doesn't like fat chicks and then gets
fat isn't that a form of fraud two she
claims that women initiate divorce 80%
of the time implying they break up
families critics say she oversimplifies
divorce reasons and should respect
divorce couple's choices three Pearl
argues that men have it harder due to a
higher suicide rate but some disagree
highlighting women's unique challenges
uh four she denies the existence of a
patriarchy and a gender gap critics
point out that historical inequalities
and ongoing challenges women face in
various aspects of Life opinions on
Pearl vary with some supporting her
views well other finding them
insensitive to women's issues I think
I've heard enough about women's issues
yes I get it you have Trauma from your
ex-boyfriend cheating on you yes I get
it periods are hard yes I get it men hit
on you at work boohoo Cry Me a River I'm
tired of hearing about it I'm tired of
hearing about how special women are and
amazing when the truth of the matter is
that you can't improve as a woman if you
are told you're amazing and special all
the time and what you're going to
continue to see is an flux of
narcissistic women who are just told
they're so awesome and special and who
cannot admit basic truths like younger
women are hotter okay so um they said I
think she's experienced abuse and is now
trying to be perfect in the eyes of a
male Society I think it's a subconscious
defense mechanism or she's a smart wh
business woman who doesn't care about
Society so let me get this straight it's
either I'm a businesswoman
or I have been abused and now I'm
perfect and now I'm trying to be perfect
you know it's so funny reading these
comments shows me why men should never
open up to women because what women will
do is if you ever open up to them and
tell them a sad story they will
attribute everything you do for a
lifetime to that sad story that's why I
think it's better for men to never tell
women anything because they will
weaponize your stories and pass against
you just to be an whereas I
think she's rage farming and doesn't
believe half the she says I also
have a hunch that she isn't even
interested in men and is closeted there
there they go now the same insults they
throw at me are the same insults they
throw at men gay oh my gosh one um why
does the left use this as an insult and
two if I have a different opinion than
you I must be gay I must be gay I must
like women no no no I actually even
think the buy that girls do
nowadays is gross I don't like it no
um okay so cultural context I've read
that she's worth 100K to 300K for a
26-year-old she's learned that having
controversial opinions PID I couldn't
find much about her family except her
parents have money and their software
entrepreneurs I'm guessing she's been
studying the business of influence into
to the point um and to your point
doesn't care about Society that's what
they do now they'll start researching my
family and everybody around me in order
to come up with with how on Earth I came
up with an opinion
very funny Behavior yes my dad is an
entrepreneur but couldn't you argue that
I don't actually need money and maybe I
just think this stuff is truth is true
truth is truth regardless of who said it
and you can shoot the
messenger but it doesn't make that
message untrue and here we go again
misogyny cells she's just a hustler she
were ironically make the most money from
Men by catering to their thought process
the funny thing is I used to have an 80%
female audience on Tik Tok you can
actually make far more money marketing
to women than to men every entrepreneur
knows this women are dummies they just
buy damn near anything men are a lot
harder to sell because they're logical
smart people all right I have one word
to describe her it ribes with the word
runt oh I had to think about what that
was all right she's horrible to women it
puts them down she thinks it's okay to
tell women how they mean nothing unless
they are young and pure and pretty
um that's not what I say I never said
nothing I say that the most ideal women
are young pure and pretty don't shoot
the messenger and shooting me the
Messenger will not change the reality of
the situation yes guys sometimes in life
us women need to take Al's and stop
crying about it I've talked to hookers
only fans models and many sex workers
that understand this reality and they
don't cry about it they just deal with
the situation and the truth of the
matter is reality will hit you in the
face one way or another whether you like
it or not she's always spouting out
these facts and statistics but I'm
starting to think she makes them up or
get them from sources that lie and
that's another thing that the left will
do they will try to discredit you by
whining about your sources and you could
provide them Source after Source after
source and they still will not care
because they want to believe what they
believe she's just horrible to other
women which is probably the worst thing
okay so she doesn't agree that women
should be promiscuous that's her opinion
fine it's not what I think it's what men
desire don't shoot the messenger for
telling you what men like but does she
have to make women who like casual sex
look and feel like crap I can't stand
her I can't make you feel anything the
way you feel comes from within you
cannot M nobody can make you feel shame
if you feel shame that comes from
somewhere and you need to deal with it
she has a nasty personality and is just
ugly I can't understand her and how she
tries to make modern women look like the
worst thing in the world I wouldn't say
the worst thing in the
world but maybe one of the worst things
in though sorry guys okay electrical
head I'm right-wing female late 20s I
don't agree with everything she says she
seems to choose a narrow view of things
and sticks to her guns regardless of if
she's wrong she has an interest you know
what's so funny they'll say she sticks
to her guns regardless of if she's wrong
and yet I'll give you point point after
point of things I've changed my opinion
on I am always willing to change my
opinion with new information what I'm
not going to do is have leftists
convince me that water is not wet the
sky is not blue and that men love
for wives and mothers I'm sorry you can
you can give me some corn statistics
with mil no that will not convince me
that men are dying to wife up single
mothers water is wet the sky is blue and
they want to shoot the messenger one
thing I'll say though is I find her
personality to be extremely
irritating I I feel like sometimes she
isn't really stating a clear point she's
just jabbing at people to be
controversial she caters to her male
guest so it's so funny they go into all
this stuff I I she gets some enjoyment
of playing the cool girl but they can't
say you're wrong do you notice that do
you notice that they just keep going on
and on about my intentions and da d d oh
she's doing this for money but but they
can't say pearl you're wrong and if they
do it's usually some it's
usually and you know I I am all for
developing a new
opinion I didn't understand why men were
would fear marriage when I first got
into this space but when you start to
interview the men that have been through
it you start to understand very quickly
why men fear marriage now to end this
episode episode my producers have gotten
me a Reddit story now I have not read
this until now so let's see what the ask
Pearl
advice
oh my wife cheated eight times but I
still love her I've been married to my
wife for a short time but we've been
together for 6 years she's always
struggled with mental health issues like
depression ADHD and anxiety which seemed
to worsen during Co she lost her job but
found another with irregular hours and
I've always tried to support
her her first mistake what is she doing
stripping after her wedding she got Co
twice and suffered from long lasting
symptoms during her recovery she started
going out more going to bars late
staying outl and sometimes came home
drunk I thought that this was an
unhealthy coping mechanism but my
attempts to discuss it were met with
defensiveness one day I discovered she
had cheated on me during her outings I
confronted her and she expressed deep
remorse attributing her actions to a
desire for attention and feeling trapped
her therapist seemed to initially blame
me but my wife later took some
responsibility now she wants space but
hasn't been home much I fear she may
demand a separation and I'm torn between
wanting her to be healthy in the
perception that I'm controlling I just
want her back how do you guys think I
can get her back she's the love of my
life I have done everything for her it
just breaks my heart that she's with
some guy at the bar women will never
respect respect you unless you are
willing to walk away I don't say this in
a happy way but this mentality repulses
women it is absolutely repulsive that a
woman can cheat on you eight times and
put up with it now a lot of times people
ask me my opinion on men and women
cheating I think that men should be able
to leave when women cheat and women
should
not I think I think that now this might
be hypocritical but I think men and
women are different when women cheat
they typically cheat to leave or to do
better they typically are cheating with
the intention of divorcing and leaving
men on the other hand cheat it's more of
a casual one-time thing because the sex
was there and available most cheating is
a one-time thing this is abnormal to
cheat eight
times that is crazy now I'm not one to
push for divorce but I do think that
this calls for it and this mentality is
sad why would you want a woman back
that's cheated on you times guys women
will not respect you unless you are
willing to leave and not put up with
their now guys um let me know
what you think in the comments and feel
free to submit Reddit stories to me on
Instagram for ask Pearl make sure you
like the video on your way out and
subscribe to the channel bring that
notification Bell and I'll talk to you
next time